if the psychic came in and fixed your
problem that person wouldn't be a
psychic and it wouldn't that and the
powers that control the psychic
experience wouldn't be who they are
either well you hit the nail on the head
it's a hamster wheel but they're getting
a taste of something that fulfills them
for 50 minutes yeah and then because
it's not what they're really needing
right they're looking for peace they're
looking for Joy they're looking for
answers they're looking for wisdom
they're looking for knowledge but
they're going to the wrong team for that
they're going to the Demonic side of
this not to God so everything that
they're looking for the devil will
promise you but he can't really deliver
right so you're on that hamster wheel it
escalates Michael like you start with
the tarot cards even my own life then it
goes to numerology astrology psychic
mediumship I had my Palms read three
million times I even did some witchcraft
spells with a couple of friends it
wasn't really my particular uh you know
expertise correct Forte right but I did